right this is gonna be fun
[Music]
okay I need to start talking about the
Doctor Who stuff that came out of San
Diego comic-con
now there was a fair amount of it and
I'm not gonna do it all in one video
basically there's three things that I
want to talk about
there was the series 11 trailer there
was what was talked about at the Doctor
Who panel and then there was that we had
the formal real finely as opposed to
league stuff of the new sonic
screwdriver I am gonna talk about all
three of those in separate videos and
I'm not doing what I did yesterday
trying to cover all the other trailers
from comic-con and do them all in one
day I'm gonna space them out across the
week yeah that's that's how this is
gonna go down so you're getting Doctor
Who spread out over a lot more time than
usually happens around here so hope you
enjoy that so this video is dealing only
with the trailer so I like it a lot
there's a lot that I like here and it
and it puts my mind to ease on some of
my fears going in because I had there
there are things that I have wanted from
Doctor Who for a while and a sense of
fun is one of them that's not to say
that doctor who has ever lost its sense
of fun but one of the things that kind
of happened under Moffett was a lot of
real darkness there was a lot of I mean
and this existed in Daviess era - I
don't want to let him off the hook he
kind of started this but Moffitt's
continuation of it made me sick of it
which is a lot of this emphasis of the
darkness and how hard life is for the
doctor and how just unpleasant
his existence is and we lost a sense of
fun and on episodes where we got that
back I always really enjoyed it it's one
of the things I honestly really liked
about robot of Sherwood which is an
episode I know not a lot of not everyone
liked and some people seem to really not
like it but
that had that sense of fun that I feel
like is in a minority so when we have a
trailer that the last thing that the
doctor says is this will be fun that's
reassuring to me in addition to that the
few little bits of dialogue we get from
her I'm finding really interesting now
I'm now gonna proceed to overanalyze and
read probably way too more into this
than should be now first of all I like
the contrast that given that the teaser
that I talked about before focus pretty
much exclusively on the companions even
though they didn't have anything to say
they were the emphasis this is much more
focused on the doctor all the things we
hear is her speaking we see more of her
and I'm liking all the sentiments I'm
liking this whole thing of it's all new
new places new times new face all of it
and I think that taking the opportunity
of not only a regeneration but a change
of the guard behind the scenes to sort
of give a little bit of a clean slate
not in a reboot sense banana look this
is our chance to tinker with stuff so
we're gonna take her with stuff in which
Moffat kind of did too when he
introduced Smith he redesigned the
TARDIS not only interior but exterior
and you know picked up on almost nothing
that could have been picked up on from
from the Davies era so I I think that's
fine I think that's a perfectly sound
option so I'm good with that I like the
I like just the emphasis on new because
I think excessive reiteration of stuff
that had already appeared in some form
or another be it's recurring villains or
the fact that you know it seemed like
the problems the doctor was dealing with
especially when we got to series finales
each time felt very similar and that we
you know we have to save the universe
again you know again not absolutely
every time but it felt like these
recurring things so anything that wants
to be a sense of not this this is the
doctor experiencing this for the first
time which was another thing that was
starting to bother me is that felt like
the doctor had become a bit of a been
everywhere seen everything because in
some ways he literally had but I like
the idea that this doctor is going to be
look
for what's new I remember one of my
favorite moments in series two was David
Tennant seeing a werewolf and going oh
you're beautiful I would love to get
that sense of discovery back because
again that along with the more outright
fun stuff is something that has been
dwindling as the as the show has gone
along so the other thing I love the line
if I ask really nicely will you be my
best friends because on the one hand it
feels very consistent with the doctor in
terms of the doctor needs companions but
the doctor especially in modern who has
generally been a bit on the reluctant
side to just take people on there have
been a couple exceptions here or there
but initially then I thought her didn't
want to travel with rose and then you
know he made a pitch to her and got her
on board the doctor just kind of
stumbled across Martha Donna practically
muscled her way in did Oh Amy to a
certain degree you know and you know
Clara he got obsessed with because he
kept running into her bill was bill was
again he kind of stumbled onto her I was
like yeah I could travel with you but
this idea that she's actively seeking
companions it's the doctors need of a
companion is very consistent with how
the doctor has always been but the idea
of sort of that maybe this version of
the doctor has gained that self
awareness where she's not like fighting
against it or reluctant to take new
companions on anymore that would be nice
and again it lends itself to the
slightly lighter touch the sense of fun
like well I could go on these adventures
myself or I could go on them with my
best friends will you be my best friend
so we can all go on this adventure
together
I'm just really loving the vibes of this
I mean visuals are scattershot and brief
and not a tend to go on we've got her
kind of gripping her head and that was a
shot of her like in her outfit because
we've got a fair amount of stuff that
I'm pretty sure it's from the first
episode were see very clearly still in
Capaldi's
outfit so I don't know if that sort of
head grab if that's gonna be something
that's like she's having issues with the
newer generation or if that's just
something that's going on in that story
specifically whatever one it's pulled
from don't know but you know I'll be
interested and I'm continuing to the
more I see and hear Jody would occur in
this part the more I am enjoying what I
see and I'd said before that even as I
saw more of Jody Whitaker's work and
other stuff he's an even as I saw
broadchurch or whatever it wasn't really
impacting my thoughts on her casting as
the doctor one way or the other cuz yes
she's a good actress but I didn't feel
like I had seen what she would be
bringing to the doctor but now I'm
actually seeing her in the part and I'm
seeing it and I'm liking it
I like this trailer I like this trailer
a lot I like the vibe that it implies
about the overall tone I like the sense
of her in the character that we are
getting and I am really excited to
continue to talk more about this
especially in light of some of the stuff
regarding what was said at the panel and
then I'll talk about the sonic
screwdriver but those are going to be
over the next few days not in a row I
actually plan to break them up so
assuming I don't rearrange my schedule
again which is possible then I'll talk
about the panel on Tuesday and the sonic
screwdriver on Thursday with some other
stuff in between because you know I've
long resisted this becoming just a
Doctor Who channel I don't want to do
too many days in a row but I do have
more stuff to talk about I'm gonna keep
talking about it but just talking about
the trailer what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drops on me
down the comments let's talk about it
there's all the stuff to do you don't
know me you don't need me to tell you
patreon is the big one
but links for that and a whole bunch of
other stuff that involves me in some way
is all linked in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]